she'd survived a long string of scandals
the murder of sarah everard by a met
police officer allegations then of a
culture of misogyny rooted in the force
two officers jailed for sharing photos
of the bodies of two sisters a report
into the murder of daniel morgan which
found institutional corruption in the
met and that cressida dick herself had
hampered that inquiry and behind each
scandal there was the damage to people's
lives such as daniel morgan's brother
alistair
she prolonged my family's suffering for
years and years and years and in fact my
mother died
before she ever saw the report so you
feel she should have resigned
a long time ago
in my view
photographers caught a glimpse of
cressida dick arriving at the job she's
now leaving there's an irony of course
that the mets first female commissioner
was ultimately sunk over concerns about
women's safety and sexist attitudes in
the force from the police handling of
sarah average vigil to last month's
report into charing cross police station
that found officers joking about rape
i think the mets problems are far from
solved with her going
but i think that unfortunately she
failed to
grapple with the issue
of misogyny and policing as well as
racism and homophobia as we've seen
and she has failed to tackle in
particular the issue of police
perpetrated abuse
in a letter seen by sky news cressida
dick had written to officers a week ago
telling them that if they were racist
homophobic or sexist they should leave
the force but it wasn't enough to
satisfy london's mayor sadiq khan who
called a meeting which he didn't tell
the home secretary about warning crested
dick that he might withdraw his
confidence so she tended her resignation
the home office has been caught by
surprise on this pretty patel apparently
calling london's mayor rude and
unprofessional the home secretary not
giving tv interviews today but writing
in the standard said whoever takes up
the role will face stark challenges to
win back public confidence in the
integrity and professionalism of the
police
in other words she agrees change was
needed but it's about more than just
replacing the person at the top many
officers agree
i'm saddened at the loss of a respected
senior leader someone i've known since i
was a sergeant
but i am appalled by the sequence of
wrongdoings
shocking situations
and occurrences that have so badly
damaged public confidence and so whilst
i'm saddened by dame crested are leaving
very obviously
what we need to do is roll up their
sleeves and address these very
significant issues which i say
exist across the whole of policing this
is not simply a metropolitan problem
she was well respected as a leader among
the ranks and by politicians which is
how she'd survived until now but it's
argued that government shouldn't decide
who comes next whilst they themselves
are under investigation by the met
police
jason farrell sky news